yeah
you can do this with alcohol
or drugs that would be fun
hey everybody it's Bert kreiser
and these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
I don't even want to know what it is
throw my way
oh you start with the goat
start with the oh this is the best snack
there is this is my go-to snack anytime
I have a snack this is what I want I
remember the first time I was introduced
to combos I was in New York twitter had
just become a thing and I opened these
and I tried one and I said and then
you'll find this tweet hey combos you
just redefined my palette
what other flavors do we have coming and
the Tweet went viral people were like
whale and whiskey would be a good combo
or how about sperm and and tequila and I
even
tried to do a combos Comedy Tour where
you take two different styles of Comedy
pair them together combo sponsor them
combos on all the table combos written
behind combos [__] rock bird Chrysler
Cat Williams combos but they're a
Christian based company and they said no
but they're snacks
oh so freaking good
okay okay okay
the cocaine of snacks
[Music]
have you guys done cocaine before
if you've done it you know it delivers
someone goes you want to try it and
you're like I don't know will I like it
yeah you'll like it it's cocaine
obviously cocaine and blow jobs both
deliver these are so good
we were in Bali my wife does not like
Doritos
and I'd had these These are the sweet
chili Doritos I said baby just try one I
promise you if you try one you will love
them my wife ate the whole bag in bed
watching TV and kept doing this
how good these
these five people and it is sweet but it
ain't that sweet they're so good they
make all the other Doritos look
pedestrian all the other Doritos are
just kissing and necking these are
finger [__]
oh yeah oh baby double stuffed Oreos
all right what kind of person are you
are you the kind of person that goes
into a grocery store and doesn't get a
case of double stuffed Oreos every time
you walk in you need them in your house
if a child ever walks in your house
how do you expect to entertain them
these things have the gold they have the
goods and it's the thing I bond with my
daughters on I love when we go food
shopping and you grab one and slide it
in the bag and go don't tell Mom I
walked in one time my daughter was
sitting in our pantry by herself eating
Oreos and I walked in and she went and I
said what she goes oh I thought you were
mom close the door
open [__] awesome
these are As Good As baseball
and oral sex these are [__] standards
of our country Communists didn't have
these and that's why we won
a whim the second time
uh here we go
oh Nutter Butters come on if we're going
sweet snack Nutter butter is the Home
Run I was introduced to Nutter Brothers
my freshman year of college
my buddy worked at Nabisco that summer I
discovered four things marijuana
Widespread Panic Sonic the Hedgehog and
Nutter Butters and I've never had a
better summer in my life and I'm so
creepy what I would do is I would get
high I play Sonic the Hedgehog and I'd
fan out a whole plate of Nutter Butters
and let them get a day old stale oh it's
nothing better than a Dale stale Nutter
butter
is so good am I am sampling all these
I'm pretty sure I was pretty strict diet
on a strict diet
lunatic
oh shut the [__] up dude rap snacks Rock
there is I don't know if it's they don't
have the same regulations as other
snacks but these are so good as you eat
them they go this can't be right what
are they doing different you ever had a
chef make dinner at your house and then
you go how do you do that with all the
stuff in my refrigerator that's what a
rap snack is they're so freaking good
and they all deliver one of my tour bus
knows we we [__] with rap snacks
oh
wow
[Music]
the woman that plays my wife in my movie
The Machine she booked the part and she
made an interesting acting Choice
throughout the audition she was talking
to me
and she was eating something
and my wife
said that woman Stephanie needs to play
your wife that's your wife in the movie
but more importantly what the [__] is
she eating
so we do a call back with Stephanie and
tell her she got the part and Leanne
goes what are you eating she goes flip
sides I'll smug them into Serbia when we
go to Serbia for that first week I'll
introduce them to you they're addictive
one side's a pretzel one side's a
cracker and it is next level we hum
through a box of these at our house you
got all the crisp up top and then all
the buttery part of like a Ritz cracker
on the back and they it it's just so
complex
but they're [__] amazing does anyone
ever had these before
yes
and yes
this is the Triad of Americana if you're
getting this in a foreign country and
there's subtitles on here and you're
going what is that well this is what
defines us As Americans if you want to
get to our heart it's these if you go to
a a a barbecue of any short you will see
one of these three probably
more of these two but these were the
game changers to these two and they're
like three sisters okay it depends who
do you want to fall in love with this
obviously is the oldest sister she reads
she's got dark hair she's got brown eyes
she's tall she doesn't do any sports
foreign
but she's fun to talk to
this is her middle sister okay
she smokes weed
he's a little thicker she's a waitress
she's got blonde hair she's still got
brown eyes but she does know how to
party she likes ipas she likes [__]
fish and she likes to like sleep
Outdoors
wow this is their younger sister beware
of her okay
she's the one that doesn't talk at
Thanksgiving she's got a short haircut
and a Bob it's blonde She's Got Crystal
Blue Eyes she's got a nose ring
and after dinner she goes you want to do
Molly tonight and you're like I'm dating
one of your sisters and she goes I don't
give a [__]
my dad says we can take the horses out
if we just bring him back don't put them
up wet you wanna do that on Molly and
then you're like why the [__] am I
dating these two and I could be married
to her because you eat her by the
handful
mm-hmm
you can do this with alcohol
or drugs that would be fun like hey I
like mushrooms oh okay all right it's
been 45 minutes
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much for watching me eat
my favorite snacks I hope you love
snacks as much as I do I hope you love
comedy as much as I do and if you do
check out my special Razzle Dazzle
streaming right now on Netflix and don't
forget by moving the machine comes out
Memorial Day Weekend only in theaters go
to the machine dot movie and I'll see
you at the movies
thank you so much guys
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign